[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
chile que digo un momento político de
efervescencia con unas elecciones a la
vuelta de la esquina y con el futuro muy
incierto del presidente actual sebastián
piñera me acompañan en este estudio
rubén curiel periodista independiente
buenos días a la un winston cecil fali
es geógrafo de la universidad parís uno
especialista en teorías de la producción
metropolización y medio ambiente en
particular en chile bienvenida y manuel
su zar de doctorando en historia de en
el instituto de altos estudios
latinoamericanos manuel buenos días
elecciones en chile hoy en primera plana
[Música]
chiles en chile se vive una de las
campañas más importantes de los 31 años
de democracia del país con la mitad de
los 15 millones de electores indecisos y
en pleno cambio de paradigma
institucional tras la crisis social de
2019 en los últimos sondeos dieron el
primer lugar al ultraderechista jose
antonio kast seguido de cerca o empatado
incluso por el izquierdista gabriel
boric y a todo esto y por añadir más
incertidumbre el futuro del propio
presidente sebastián piñera depende
ahora de un juicio político tras su
aparición en los papeles de pana de
pandora por las supuestas
irregularidades en la venta en islas
vírgenes británicas de un polémico
proyecto minero vamos a repasar toda
esta coyuntura política pero antes
algunas portadas el mercurio
precisamente trata con esta portada la
situación de piñera con controvertida
estrategia dice el diario la oposición
logra aprobar inédita acusación
constitucional al presidente tribunas
como esta otra del mostrador intentan
dar las claves para explicar el ascenso
del ultraderechista cast la migración la
violencia y el conflicto chileno mapuche
son tres temas en los que ha crecido
fértil la candidatura según el diario
las últimas noticias hablan del otro
favorito para meterse en segunda vuelta
más impuestos a los combustibles medida
del izquierdista boris que encendió el
debate en la universidad de chile bueno
lo primero que les quiero preguntar y
empezado por ustedes rubén que se juega
chile en estas elecciones
se juega un futuro muy incierto porque
el panorama que va a tener el próximo
presidente no es tan claro porque el
marco constitucional puede cambiar hay
demandas sociales que aún están
insatisfechas
y bueno igual lo que va a tener ese
próximo presidente no está dando es tan
claro en
chile
lo que se está jugando
tiene que ver mucho con el proceso
constituyente qué
que empezó hace ahora dos años en chile
se está redactando una nueva
constitución hay muchas oposiciones
entre el congreso actual y la asamblea
la convención constituyente
si sale moritz podría acompañar este
proceso que es histórico para chile si
sale cast
la oposición va a seguir y puede ser un
peligro muy importante para chile me
parece claro se mencionaba en estos dos
nombres que son los que han aparecido a
estar en los sondeos el ultraderechista
cast y el izquierdista a boris los
sondeos han ido configurando manuel un
panorama polarizado en un país de
diferencia de otros de la región hasta
ahora había votado opciones mucho más a
la europea podríamos decirlo claro
justamente lo que tú dices se está
generando un ambiente polarizado pero
que tal vez no es tan polarizado se está
tratando de poner a kast ya vori como
iguales como una especie de dos demonios
cuando la realidad no tendría por qué
ser así un gas es claramente un
candidato de extrema derecha o un
candidato de izquierda mucho más europeo
en ciertos aprontes que lo que podría
ser casta por ejemplo o sea que
tendríamos a diferenciar a moritz de
otros candidatos populistas de la
izquierda latinoamericana claro no sería
castillo por ejemplo en perú no es lo
que podrían haber sido los kirchner en
argentina no es necesariamente lo mismo
vamos a analizar ambas figuras los
últimos sondeos daban la primera plaza
ajustada josé antonio kast expliquemos
que tienes casi de dónde sale rubén pues
lo que pasa es que a lo que apela acá
este es un voto casi nostálgico y apela
a temas
que son la economía que son la
inmigración y el orden que son temas que
aparecen muchos en países como podrían
parecer también en francia por ejemplo
pero donde el debate se descentraliza en
algo que no que no es en el top 3 o 5 de
las preocupaciones de los chilenos
porque después de esta visión social los
tilos tienen nos pedían más justicia y
metían los derechos humanos a la en el
top de esas preocupaciones y esos no son
los temas que caster prioriza podemos
identificar a casas con un portón
nostálgico del pinochetismo o no sólo es
esto cecil si yo pienso que sí pero
también hay qué
y ponerlo dentro del contexto regional
latinoamericano no tanto mundial o
europeo viendo lo que pasó en brasil por
supuesto con alguien como jair bolsonaro
es exactamente el mismo tipo de discurso
sobre los indígenas por ejemplo
el mando también de las fuerzas armadas
que reinvindica
es muy regional más que preocupación
mundial diría manuel claro más allá de
una nostalgia por pinochet que lo más
probable es que tenga el diputado ex
diputado de la udi es una persona de
derecha tradicional en chile sin embargo
yo creo que obedece mucho más a una
derecha moderada entre comillas que no
sabía instalarse en chila ahí está la
fuerza de cast en llenar un vacío que la
derecha liberal por ejemplo no supo
ganar en chile sí de hecho durante las
últimas semanas hemos visto a figuras de
la derecha moderada abrazar la opción de
josé antonio kast en vez de la del
candidato oficialista
de piñera porque se ha producido esta
situación es puro pragmatismo sabiendo
que cas va bien en los sondeos porque
porque se está produciendo esta
situación pues es una alianza casi ética
casi o que lo tienen que hacer porque
cuando los sondeos son tan
polarizados cuando tienes
ratings tan importantes a dos semanas de
los comicios ya tienes que hacer
alianzas porque ya no se entiende si hay
cuatro bloques diferentes
el chileno no sabe cuál va a ser su
panorama así que me parece que así pues
es un tema político manuel o si es un
voto bastante estratégico por parte de
la derecha hay que pensar que en estos
momentos la derecha viene una elección
parlamentaria donde tienen un candidato
de gobierno muy débil no tienen casi
representación importante es la
constituyente lo más probable es que van
a perder la presidencial entonces que
les quiera aferrarse a este salvavidas
que podría ser cast que les guarde
cuatro años de poder en el gobierno y a
todo esto el propio sebastián piñera
vive momentos muy delicados su
destitución depende ahora de un juicio
político tras su aparición en los
papeles de pandora por las supuestas
irregularidades en la venta en islas
vírgenes y vírgenes británicas de un
polémico proyecto minero que futuro
tiene este proceso y de que va a
depender su eventual destitución
quien quiera rubén pues un cierto porque
ya no le quedan muchos días al mundo y
pues la correlación de fuerzas no es tan
evidente en el senado tiene que pasar
por el senado a ese proceso lo que llama
la intensión en chile es que es la
primera vez que se hace un juicio
político en así y pues se hace por temas
económicos y parece que pues los temas
económicos son más funcionales más
graves que los temas de los derechos
humanos porque piñera tenía una
acusación constitucional en 2019 después
del estallido y bueno eso es poco
paradójico y llama la atención de los
chilenos porque pone poner la política y
el de los temas económicos
las más importantes que otros temas que
ya tienen los chilenos me gustaría
preguntarnos qué efecto creen que tiene
el caso piñera en la campaña si creen
que tiene algún tipo de efecto es bueno
el primer fue
debilitar mucho a sitel que era la
personalidad de centroizquierda
que tenía un papel importante en el
gobierno de piñera justamente que era el
más sintético de los candidatos el menos
polarizado y eso ya es algo importante y
ahora llega alguien de extrema izquierda
a derecha- perdón y otra de izquierda
que
parece que a lo mejor falta un poco
puede ser de personalidades joven para
presentarse así que ya es el primer es
la consecuencia directa de los pandora
papers pero por lo que me cuentan claro
el candidato oficial oficialista de
piñera sichel es un candidato moderado
con un perfil centrista que a lo mejor
no encaja en la actual coyuntura
política chilena es decir o puede que no
encaje pero la gente que lo financiaba
en un comienzo y su equipo político
estaba muy ligado a lo que era el
piñerismo entonces sí encajaba llegado
un momento si encajó era el candidato
que no era político habiendo servido en
muchos partidos políticos y gobiernos
era el candidato joven que el candidato
que representaba si se quiere una
especie de boris pero de centroderecha
esta persona joven con ideas que están
definiendo un perfil me parece al
presidente francés a la crono un perfil
muy parecido
cuando el manual marco no salió elegido
con francia mucha gente se disputaba a
quienes el macro en chileno y todavía no
aparece al parecer en cuanto a la
izquierda del voto favorito de los
sondeos es gabriel boric el voto de la
juventud chilena va a depender mucho en
en las eventuales posibilidades de boris
en un balotaje entiendo rubén pues el
otro de varitas más joven pero también
el pudo meter los temas qué
que estallaron después del estallido
social
como la justicia como la genera
desigualdad y después puso su programa
este vaso en esos temas me parece que
manuel que tiene más conocimiento de los
jóvenes en chile pues sí es decir
el voto jóvenes es un voto muy de boris
no hay una fractura generacional uno del
gobierno tendería a pensar que sí sin
embargo es importante notar que que
boris en su campaña puso en algún
momento la frase jóvenes somos todos
abuelos ancianos adultos todos eran
jóvenes de espíritu entonces lo que él
necesita más allá de un voto joven que
pueda existir o no es que gente que no
va a votar vaya a votar para tratar de
aumentar su bolsón de otros claro de
hecho para añadir algo en su programa
participativo que no llamó a la gente el
primer tema que llega es el tema de las
pensiones que no es un tema de jóvenes
el tema de jóvenes que sería el cambio
climático etcétera llega muy muy tarde
en su programa el primer es los
pensiones
justamente
diría yo sobre el punto de la
solidaridad del pueblo chileno de esta
dignidad de los derechos humanos de
cuidar a sus viejitos como se dice es
algo muy importante para él y en su
programa y para la gente y en esta
polarización que estamos describiendo
del panorama actual político chileno hay
un factor generacional cuanto menos no
por lo que me están contando manuel es
decir si yo creo que sí se puede se
puede se puede encontrar pero finalmente
a la hora de votar la gente que vota en
chileno ha cambiado mucho se pueden
encontrar en el fondo atenuantes se votó
por ejemplo el plebiscito en pandemia
con restricciones se verá el próximo
domingo si efectivamente esta fractura
generacional existe como tal o no
mejorar unos segundos vamos a ir a una
breve pausa y enseguida vamos a
continuar analizando la situación en
chila quien en primera plana está ahora
ah
[Música]
y
fue publicado el tercer borrador del
acuerdo final de la cob 26 las
negociaciones se extendieron hasta este
sábado debido a la falta de consenso el
documento urge a los países más ricos a
duplicar para 2025 su apoyo financiero a
las naciones menos favorecidas con
respecto a los niveles de 2019
las autoridades polacas encontraron el
cuerpo de un joven sirio cerca de la
frontera con belarús se trata de la
última víctima que deja la crisis que
tiene a miles de emigrantes durmiendo a
la intemperie y esperando cruzar a
territorio europeo rusia aliado de
belarús negó que tuviera algo que ver
con la situación
francia conmemora el sexto aniversario
de los atentados de parís de 2015 que
dejaron 130 personas muertas el primer
ministro y la alcaldesa de parís
depositaron flores en los sitios
atacados por el estado islámico el
homenaje se da mientras avanza el mega
juicio contra 20 personas acusadas de
haber participado en los atentados
hola y bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
de noticias en france 24 los saluda
andrés meza muñoz
empezamos con noticias de la cob 26
donde se extienden las negociaciones
para llegar a un acuerdo final en medio
de una mezcla de escepticismo y
optimismo se publicó el tercer borrador
sobre lo pactado hasta ahora en el
documento se insta a los países ricos a
duplicar para 2025 el financiamiento
para la adaptación al cambio climático
de países en desarrollo con respecto a
los niveles de 2019 previamente nuestra
enviada especial marina colorado
conversó con vanessa pérez cirera del
programa de clima y energía del fondo
mundial para la naturaleza sobre qué tan
creíble es el compromiso de los líderes
en la lucha contra el cambio climático
pues yo creo que la credibilidad ya se
venía desde el principio de la cumbre no
sea lo vimos en las calles desde el
principio de la cumbre la gente que está
afuera dice bueno prometieron ustedes
cumplir con el acuerdo de parís
prometieron ustedes llegar al comienzo
de la implementación del acuerdo de
parís con los planes alineados al 1.5 en
lo cual no ha sucedido con el
financiamiento a los 100 billones lo
cual no ha sucedido
ciertamente pues ahí afuera les creemos
no les creemos lo que acuerdan acá lo
cumplirán y la única manera de romper
con esa con esa falta de credibilidad es
es dar acciones concretas es hacer
nuestros planes de mitigación al cambio
climático alineados a los objetivos de
parís alineados pero alineados a lo que
ya está aquí se reconoce como el 1.5
grados entonces necesitan los países
alinear esos planes pero ya dar
resultados en la implementación eso es
lo único que va a poder saldar digamos
esa brecha de credibilidad que ahora que
ahora existe yo creo que los ciudadanos
ya le han dado el espacio a los
gobiernos para hacerlo lo que
necesitamos es que los gobiernos actúen
sobre ese liderazgo político la crisis
migratoria en la frontera entre polonia
y belarús parece estar lejos de acabar
la policía polaca confirmó el hallazgo
del cuerpo de un joven sirio en esa zona
se trata de la última víctima mortal que
deja la situación que tiene enfrentados
a los países europeos y al gobierno
bielorruso al que acusan de alentar la
migración ilegal a través de su
territorio a manera de represalia por
las sanciones impuestas contra minsk el
presidente ruso vladimir putin negó que
su país tuviera algo que ver en la
crisis y desde su gobierno
responsabilizaron a la unión europea de
una inminente catástrofe quiero que todo
el mundo sepa que nosotros no tenemos
nada que ver con esto todos están
tratando de hacernos responsables por
algo en todo momento dada la oportunidad
o incluso sin ella nuestras aerolíneas
no transportan a estas personas ni una
sola compañía de hecho tampoco lo hace
la aerolínea bielorrusa del abya según
me aseguró alexandr lukashenko ellos
toman vuelos chárter con entrada libre
de visas esta gente compra sus tiquetes
y va y es que son miles los migrantes
que se las arreglan para sobrevivir en
la frontera mientras intenta cruzar no
solo se enfrentan al hambre y al frío
algunos también son víctimas del
excesivo uso de la fuerza por parte de
las autoridades de polonia y belarús un
equipo de france 24 se fue el terreno
para investigar
en bolonia cerca de la frontera
bielorrusa un grupo de sirios consiguió
salir de la zona restringida
unos voluntarios polacos les brindan
ayuda cómo se sienten tengo demasiado
frío tienes frío tienes comida o agua no
hay seis adultos y un niño estos
colchones los necesitan dicen que han
sido rechazados varias veces por los
guardias fronterizos de polonia
intentamos volver a nuestro país porque
ya sabes no podemos cruzar la frontera
pero cuando intentamos volver a ming el
ejército bielorruso nos atrapó y algunos
fuimos golpeados puede contarnos un poco
más sobre lo que ocurrió donde lo
atraparon que hicieron en el lado polaco
vale he intentado cruzar la frontera
nueve veces también y un coche
este grupo no quiere ser visto que otro
toma sus datos por si acaso
si la policía nos atrapa te llamamos
así puede llamarnos pero aunque los
voluntarios pueden ayudar con la
asistencia jurídica y alimentos no
pueden ofrecer mucha esperanza
placeres sinceros tenemos muchos grupos
que son rechazados así que estos sirios
no van a pedir asilo sino a probar
suerte en el bosque adiós de vuelta a
varsovia que otro confiesa su
desesperación por ver las autoridades
polacas devolver a todos estos migrantes
al bosque helado
quieren que la gente muera para
desanimar a los demás y esto no sólo es
ilegal sino que también es inhumano no
debería ocurrir en europa y
especialmente en polonia
pero no muy lejos de la frontera en
sokol que muchos residentes apoyan la
línea dura del gobierno ven a los
migrantes como una amenaza nos van a
matar ya han robado un coche allí cuando
voy al campo me da miedo pero mi pueblo
cerca de la frontera si les dejamos
entrar vendrán cientos de miles más si
polonia lo hace la ola no solo se
extenderá al país sino a toda la unión
europea ya vimos lo que pasó en 2015
mientras tanto es imposible saber
cuántos migrantes se esconden en estos
bosques o cuántos han muerto
seguimos en europa este 13 de noviembre
se cumplen 6 años de los atentados que
dejaron 130 muertos en parís en 2015 con
un minuto de silencio y ofrendas
florales fueron recordados quienes
perdieron la vida a las afueras del
stade france en varios cafés de la
capital y en la sala de conciertos del
bataclán a los actos conmemorativos
asistieron el primer ministro jan castex
el ministro del interior ya halderman al
y la alcaldesa de parís anne hidalgo así
como familias de las víctimas
actualmente avanza en la capital
francesa el mega juicio contra los 20
acusados de haber participado en los
ataques que fueron reivindicados por el
estado islámico
mañana argentina celebrará elecciones
legislativas en las que se renovará
aproximadamente la mitad de la cámara de
diputados y un tercio de las del senado
en las primarias de septiembre pasado el
oficialismo sufrió una dura derrota que
ahora buscará revertir mientras que la
oposición intentará repetir el resultado
a los comicios también llega a
movimientos que han logrado capitalizar
el voto del descontento de partes de la
sociedad y este domingo buscarán
confirmarlo en las urnas nuestro
corresponsal natalio cosoi nos cuenta
más
como rubén díaz muchos son muy jóvenes
vinieron el cierre de campaña del
candidato a diputado ultra liberal de
derecha el economista javier mi ley y
están desencantados con la política
tradicional argentina
vi que encuentra una solución en el
tiempo en el que yo actúe
[Música]
digo básicamente y también mis padres
ver como constantemente se repite el
siglo ellos creen que mi ley con su
política de mínima intervención estatal
ayudará a impulsar leyes para lograr una
estabilidad socioeconómica en argentina
una alternativa a la que se vuelve una
parte de una opinión pública saturada
tras años de descontento como señala el
consultor jorge giacobbe una opinión
pública que votó un presidente con el
48% algún momento
tuvo de él un 68 por ciento de imagen
positiva y hoy tiene un 15 demuestra que
hay un nivel de ofensa un nivel de
desconexión un nivel de descrédito que
es enorme
desde la vereda opuesta a mi ley la
coalición del frente de izquierda
también se ha posicionado como
alternativa entre quienes están cansados
de las que consideran desacertadas
decisiones de los partidos tradicionales
de precarización a la clase trabajadora
[Música]
si bien no se espera que ninguna de
estas terceras fuerzas desplacen las
urnas a la coalición gobernante del
frente de todos ni a la oposición de
juntos por el cambio si las está
obligando a prestarle atención a esta
fuga de votos por izquierda y por
derecha si estas otras propuestas
llegaran a crecer en las elecciones del
domingo podría leerse como una evidencia
de que realmente existe una crisis de la
actual hegemonía política en el país
vigente desde hace casi 20 años
vamos a eeuu un gran jurado federal
imputó a esteban con un aliado de larga
data de la expresión todo nostrum por
negarse a testificar ante un comité del
congreso que investiga la insurrección
en el capitolio ocurrida en enero de
este año la acusación sobre el varón a
quien le han dictado dos cargos por
desacato se produce en medio de un
momento de profunda polarización
política en el país
massa en el siguiente informe
con una victoria significativa así
calificó el comité selecto de la cámara
de representantes de eeuu la decisión
del gran jurado federal de acusar a
state bank un antiguo asesor del ex
presidente de donald trump por dos
cargos de desacato adicionalmente para
los representantes la decisión envía un
mensaje disuasivo claro para quienes
pretendan obstaculizar la investigación
y es que para el comité banon podría
tener información sobre los planes para
el ataque tal como lo afirman sus
comentarios emitidos en un podcast el
día previo al residente
él dijo que todo el infierno se iba a
desatar y cito estamos llegando justo
sobre el objetivo este es el punto de
ataque que siempre hemos querido nápoles
wanted cinco personas murieron durante
el asalto al capitolio cuando los
asaltantes intentaron cerrar el congreso
bajo presuntas afirmaciones falsas de
trump de que biden había cometido un
fraude electoral en noviembre de 2020 la
acusación sobre banon es la primera que
surge de la investigación del comité de
la cámara
se anunció horas después de que el ex
jefe de gabinete de la casa blanca bajo
el mando de donald trump mark meadows
también se negara a comparecer ante el
comité barón podría enfrentar hasta un
año de prisión y una multa de 100.000
dólares y se espera que a sus 67 años se
entregue a la justicia el próximo lunes
y está abierta es una jueza del tribunal
superior del condado de los ángeles puso
fin a la tutela que ha controlado desde
2008 prácticamente todos los aspectos de
la vida profesional y personal de la
estrella del pop britney spears la
tutela que fue impuesta por el padre de
la cantante jamie spears desencadenó el
movimiento de fans whitney quienes
celebraron eufóricamente la decisión
judicial a las afueras del tribunal juan
baró lucumí tiene más detalles
britney es libre al fin una vez que la
jueza brenda penny puso fin a la tutela
que ha controlado la vida personal y el
patrimonio de 60 millones de dólares de
la cantante pop estadounidense durante
casi 14 años el júbilo estalló en las
afueras del tribunal superior de los
ángeles con cientos de fans que
celebraron la noticia
britney quien compareció a la audiencia
virtualmente no tardó en reaccionar a la
decisión en sus redes sociales dios mío
quiero tanto a mis fans que es una
locura voy a llorar el resto del día el
mejor día de mi vida alabado sea el
señor me pueden dar un amén la tutela
fue establecida por el padre de la
cantante jamie spears desde que ella
sufrió un colapso público y se sometió a
tratamientos por problemas de salud
mental no revelados en 2008 y fue tan
solo hasta septiembre de este año que la
jueza suspendió al padre del artista
como curador legal
hoy la jueza penny después de la
audiencia
decidió dar la razón a brindé spears
y a partir de hoy con efecto inmediato
la tutela se ha terminado en cuanto a la
persona y el patrimonio
rosell de éste aunque parecía que la
tutela podía continuar durante años el
emotivo discurso de spears del 23 de
junio de este año en el que describió
las restricciones impuestas en su vida
como abusivas fue clave para que no
hubiera solicitud de prórroga en la
tutela el padre de la cantante todavía
podría ser investigado por la gestión
monetaria de la artista y por
presuntamente haber implantado un
dispositivo de escucha en su dormitorio
en filipinas la hija del presidente
rodrigo duterte anunció su candidatura a
la vicepresidencia del país y no
apuntará a suceder a su padre como se
había dicho inicialmente traduce arte
actual alcaldesa de dávao tomó la
decisión luego de que el candidato a la
vicepresidencia de su partido se
retirara ahora será la compañera de
fórmula de ferdinand marcos júnior hijo
del fallecido dictador filipino que
lleva el mismo nombre ambos cargos se
eligen por separado en él y esta alianza
ya ha alertado a activistas de derechos
humanos de cara a los comicios de mayo
de 2022
y en su lucha contra el kobe 19 china
presentó lo que calificó como la primera
vacuna inhalable del mundo el fármaco
desarrollado por la farmacéutica cancino
inc que se aplica de manera oral
contiene sólo una quinta parte de la
dosis de una inyección de acuerdo con
las investigaciones tendría la misma
respuesta inmune y si se aplica como una
dosis de refuerzo a una vacuna
intramuscular podría inducir fuertes
respuestas de anticuerpos neutralizantes
esta vacuna inhalable inhalable ya había
sido aprobada para su uso de emergencia
tras los resultados arrojados en los
ensayos clínicos de fase 2
hasta aquí es informativo en francés 24
gracias por acompañarnos continúen con
toda nuestra programación
[Música]
seguimos en primera plan esta semana
analizando la coyuntura que vive chile
con elecciones a la vuelta de la esquina
y con una situación
particular y muy complicada para el
presidente sebastián piñera con un
eventual juicio político lo hacemos con
ruber curiel periodista independiente
manuel suzarte doctorando en la historia
del instituto de altos estudios
latinoamericanos y cecil fali es geobra
geógrafa de la universidad parís uno les
quería preguntar si encuentran que el
riesgo en el escenario de la post
pandemia que deje otro estallido social
en el país como el que se vivió en 2019
justo antes de la pandemia pues puede
ser porque los chilenos esperaban que
los indicadores económicos y el
crecimiento de las empresas que
mostraban esos indicadores caixes cayera
como en cascada hacia todos los sectores
de la economía nacional y eso nunca pasó
y también parece que ningún partido
político en ningún líder político puede
entender
el descontento de la gente así que me
parece que si puede haber
riesgos de otro estallido social
que enlace la situación de la post
pandemia con la de la pre pandemia en
chile depende del próximo presidente
realmente si no viene un presidente que
está
de acuerdo con el proceso de nueva
constitución de redacción de nueva
constitución el caso de cast puede haber
otro estallido social
en esta campaña de los sondeos han sido
ampliamente criticados en redes sociales
por sociólogos y encuestadores que los
acusan de manipular luego de sonados
desaciertos en sus proyecciones entre
2019 y este año cuando se votó el
plebiscito la constitución constituyente
gobernadores y alcaldes les quiero
preguntar manuel estas críticas la
demoscopia están justificadas manipular
con qué objetivos es decir entrar a
analizarse efectivamente en manipulación
o no por ejemplo para que el candidato
de derecho de gobierno gane es más
complicado pero efectivamente en avión
han habido quejas por parte de los
expertos que en el armado metodológico
de ciertas encuestas deja mucho que
desear y que no son representativas y
que finalmente a la hora de predecir
no predicen y condicionan el debate
durante meses para que por ejemplo hay
una campaña del terror contra el partido
comunista o que cassez el crema derecha
o en el fondo para ayudar más bien a
polarizar que a manejar la incertidumbre
que genera una campaña presidencial si
en octubre de 2019 explotó el
descontento social contra un modelo
neoliberal impuesto por el régimen
militar la campaña presidencial ha
sacado a la luz el auge de una
ultraderecha les quiero preguntar rubén
la ultraderecha ha sido el pinochetismo
es algo latente que ha estado ahí
durante todo este tiempo que ahora lo
vemos emerger a lo mejor con la figura
con la figura de cast o es algo que ha
estado latente y siempre
se puede ver el porcentaje no sé la
verdad pero quizás ese otro exista
existía perdón pero no había
representante no había opción no había
alguien que encarnaba también encargada
también perdón en esos temas ahora con
cast hay la persona perfecta para hablar
de eso y como lo dijo manuel él conoce
muy bien ese tema y se puede basar sobre
todo sobre esa historia para
para llegar a la presidencia me parece
es decir ese voto pinochetista ahora
encuentra en la figura de cast alguien
que representa esas ideas y que pone
esos temas en la agenda manuel sí pero
casi ha sido también lo suficientemente
hábil para nunca relacionarse
directamente con pinocho en esta campaña
y él lo sabe no no no podría decir que
él no es pinochetista o si el
pinochetismo existe no hay que olvidar
que binoche está con 44% de votos en su
plebiscito entonces claramente hay una
herencia ahí y que cast juega un poco
con esa ambivalencia no lo critica no lo
condena pero tampoco está qué sé yo con
una polera de pinochet en sus marchas
como podría ser por ejemplo bolsonaro en
cualquier caso les iba a preguntar
precisamente eso con que el líder
internacional podríamos comparar a
cascón bolsonaro quizás a la comparativa
más cercano más exacta pues es y si a mí
me parece el más actual y yo más que
compararlo a un candidato del pasado
pinochet es el pasado no no es la
actualidad aunque haya una fibra
como tú dices pero
yo quien sí sería bolsonaro y a lo mejor
unos candidatos también de otros países
como francia que no son candidatos pero
claro pero hay una revisión
efectivamente no se puede comparar mejor
un candidato de la extrema derecha de
antes con uno de ahora pero de la misma
forma que estalló un que hubo un
estallido social hay un estallido de
necesidad de autoritarismo en chile
que justifique la presencia de cast
ayunar
autor un contramovimiento
por donde voy pero sólo un poco en él en
el largo plazo es un discurso no tan
distinto al que había cuando salió
electo piñera que chile iba a ser chile
suela que se va a transformar en una
dictadura chavista o de maduro si uno lo
ve hoy día efectivamente puede haber tal
vez alza en las tasas de criminalidad
más a un problema de desigualdad pero de
ahí a decir que efectivamente se
necesita como mano dura en esta
respuesta simple a problemas complejos
que propone cast yo creo que es un poco
es estirar el argumento luego hay otro
elemento que es los indecisos la poca
claridad sobre estos comicios residen
que la intención de voto ronda el 50 por
ciento de los 15 millones de votantes
porque esta tasa de indecisos en chile
rubén pues es muy interesante lo que
decía manía de manuel a al inicio que el
voto chileno pues las mismas personas
van a votar y pues hay muchas
dificultades para esos candidatos
[Música]
entender lo que lo que piden los jóvenes
es entender lo que piensan
los nuevos que van a votar y pues eso me
parece que son tan poco desconcertados
porque no encuentran una figura que
entiende a todo lo que pidieron después
del estallido claro porque la
implantación del voto voluntario en 2012
hizo que la participación cayera esto
cómo se puede interpretar a quién puede
beneficiar manuel finalmente beneficia
al candidato y quien logre identificar
mejor a su bolsón de votos no tiene
ningún incentivo para salir a buscar
votantes nuevos si efectivamente pueden
por ejemplo cast antes de este aparición
a las encuestas cast podría asegurar
alrededor de un 10 por ciento de votos
seguro con este mismo discurso ahora se
encuentra claro en esta situación en
donde la correlación de fuerzas cambia y
con su mismo discurso un poco atenuado
puede crecer un poco más pero el
incentivo no está para salir a buscar
necesariamente nuevos votantes les debe
preguntar por la senadora demócrata
cristiana yasna provoste que sería la
tercera opción según algunos sondeos si
hay incluso podría sacar más de lo que
han proyectado los sondeos hasta ahora
que votado blue tiene esta opción rubén
manuel
que voto ya y esa es la gran pregunta
esa debería ser la candidata del centro
en rigor ella tuvo un construyó
liderazgo muy interesante durante la
pandemia como jefa del senado como
interlocutora frente a piñera sin
embargo no ha logrado posicionarse puede
ser por las encuestas puede ser
efectivamente porque su campaña no ha
sido muy bien llevada pero debería estar
por lo menos yo creo peleando el tercer
lugar
la alternancia entre dos grandes bloques
políticos es costumbres de radio sobre
la democracia desde 88 entonces el
centro no tiene tanto poder tanto no
tiene la figura para
implementarse en la cabeza de la gente
porque pues hay dos bloques políticos y
así se va a agotar y por eso el centro
no voy por el sitio una sorpresa que
esta candidata se colar en el balotaje
es decir hoy por el vamos por sentado
que el balotaje va a ser uno en la
opción de la extrema derecha contra uno
son de izquierdas según los sondeos pero
como dijo manuel y es decir ante sin
antes los sondeos no nunca nunca te van
a decir lo que va a pasar dentro de los
demás es igual yo veo que a lo mejor
ella podría en un contexto así muy
polarizado hacer como una síntesis y
alomejor asegurar a la gente ella es una
es la más profesional de los políticos
que se presentan es una mujer los
chilenos ya están acostumbrados con esta
idea y en esta práctica
también afirma sus orígenes
autóctonos del pueblo diaguita yo creo
así que es un tema yo pienso a lo mejor
podría
en el momento de votar para los
indecisos podrían decir bueno voy a
votar para ella y no para los dos polos
que parecen manuel tiene alguna opción
de colarse en un balotaje claro porque
no cuando se hablaba del plebiscito se
decía que el rechazo crecía el voto
contra la constitución y finalmente
terminó sacando casi un 80 por ciento lo
que sí es cierto que en una segunda
vuelta en un balotaje su candidatura a
la candidatura ya se aprobó este es
bastante competitiva porque
efectivamente representa el centro
representa algo más conocido no tanto el
incertidumbre que consideran que es de
estas elecciones va a salir un chile más
polarizado todavía que vamos a encontrar
dos chiles un país más fragmentado según
las opciones que ahora mismo se barajan
en los sondeos y no se lo quiero
preguntar a los 3 rubén pues juega esa
diferencia entre las generaciones
unos unas ondas que no son las mismas
entre las generaciones hay muchos temas
que parece que hacen de chile un país
polarizado y pues esas elecciones
me parece seguir en este camino
más fragmentado no puede ser no sería ya
tiene el
índice de gini de desigualdad más alto
del mundo casi
hay unos temas que no que no se pueden
sintetizar para la gente
va a seguir así no sé si más polarizado
con esa palabra fragmentado y mucho se
va a jugar en como la derecha se ve
rearticular después de la elección por
ejemplo si cast no sale presidente sí sí
que él no sale presidente vamos a tener
una derecha como le gusta pensarse
moderna o una derecha que va a centrarse
en cast y protegerse con cast finalmente
ahí yo creo que se va a jugar la
eventual polarización a no pero es
cierto que he mirado desde europa
siempre tomamos el ejemplo chileno como
el país más europeo vamos a decir de
américa latina y tomamos muy poco a
veces en cuenta el discurso de la
desigualdad de cuánta desigualdad
interna hay visto con los ojos europeos
no sé si tienen esa sensación también a
veces de cómo se trata desde europa la
cuestión chilena no es no es falso que
la la transición chilena tiene mucho la
transición española la reunificación
socialista le debe mucho a la el
socialismo francés
y por eso se es claro se votaba la
europea era un lenguaje político que
calzaba con los debates en europa pero
chile no es un país europeo no tiene
servicios sociales europeos y tiene una
desigualdad perfectamente de tercer
mundo y eso ha generado nunca tanto
problema como está generando ahora
este contexto económico además de pastón
dénia
genera un marco
incierto y pues es a esta situación
inestable
ya es evidente en chile y ya no sé no sé
de chile como un país
europeo en que los votos de centros son
los que van a diferenciar que gane casto
o boris en la segunda vuelta y hacia
dónde pueden ir esos votos de centro me
quedan unos segundos
es que una persona de centro vota no
debería votar por un candidato de
extrema derecha y sería más lógico otro
candidato de izquierda pero bueno ya sé
que la lógica de estas
buenas de un placer compartir estos
minutos de charla hablando de chile yo
creo que hemos dado un panorama
absolutamente todas las aristas hemos
tratado un montón de toda la complejidad
no de la situación de la coyuntura
política chilena muchísimas gracias
manuel rubén cecil y a todos ustedes le
esperamos la próxima semana aquí en
primera plana muchísimas gracias
[Música]